for more than three months russia's
invasion of ukraine has produced
harrowing images of war and suffering
now a group of ukrainian graphic artists
is responding to the violence with
creativity they've come together to
share their work and raise money for
their country face the nation moderator
and chief foreign affairs correspondent
mark brennan has been speaking to some
of the artists about their powerful
images
we are not
soldiers or we are not doctors being an
artist during the war like you think
people are dying in your drawing artist
anna sarvira does not know when she will
return to ukraine she's haunted by the
war you don't have an experience of the
word only if you hate hate and hate and
it's a terrible feeling i was drawn in
this feeling and when you feel only that
you cannot do anything else anna
co-founded a collective to share graphic
art from fellow illustrators most of
them decided not to leave the country
they were never stopping working and
drawing like artist alexander chatokin
as russian bombs dropped on his city he
sent ana works of art each day when i
saw this
it made me tear up he was trying to
capture all the child victims in one
picture anna's collective helped
organize more than 40 exhibitions around
the world to auction artwork and raise
money for ukraine
including at ukraine house here in
washington many of the women have left
they're refugees
anna here ana sarvira is one of them she
is now in germany
this is putin again i call it my secret
dream and i think that hope that this
war
against ukraine will end up to put him
like that with his stash he starts
something terrible miro you never
thought you could hate so much i always
felt like i'm a nice good person
illustrator tanya yacunova's work is
inspired by the bravery of ordinary
ukrainian
we have these videos where russian
shooting
and people don't even scare of the sound
of the gun
she drew even while fleeing the bombing
of keefe
and is now documenting the horrific
atrocities left behind she calls this
piece bucha mother this image is a
collective image of the several victims
who they can share their stories
unfortunately army found corpses of
several young women
naked and raped on a roadside
and russian tried to burn them tanya
used to illustrate children's books but
the war has robbed her and so many
others of that innocence
there is more stories about a woman who
was raped
in front of her small
baby
and neither woman neither
nor baby survived they were shot i felt
so much hate for people who did it this
is probably the hardest piece i ever
draw these women can't tell their
stories but you're telling their stories
i wish i would
i would never need to process
for cbs morning's margaret brennan in
washington
it is so hard to think that
november of last year this was an intact
country i mean it was fearing the worst
but and now all of this
hatred
destruction it's been so haunting to see
the winter in that country which is so
grim in terms of the spring and it looks
so beautiful but the news just gets
worse and worse it gets worse and these
people have to deal with it and it's
it's hard to watch it is hard to live
harder to live through i am sure
unfortunately this art is necessary
decades centuries from now to tell the
story of what happened to remind people
of the atrocities really nice piece for
margaret brown absolutely people cannot
forget this cannot forget what happened